well john lydon joins me now john great
to see you how are you
i'm very much alive thank you
you're all very alive i've got some very
big news i'm going to start with some
very bad news because as you know stop
it uh uh
uh you must not do that do you know what
i'm about to say to me too do you know
what i'm about to say no i don't want to
you know there's a certain you know
there's a certain football match on
tonight right no
no stop it
[Laughter]
i won't tell you but it's not good news
we need a bit of a perk up let's just
leave it like that um for those who
don't know what i'm talking about john
and i both massive arsenal fans and
we're playing a massive game tonight
against our most bitter rivals and we're
currently losing
about being massive look i'm proper
arsenal windows or draw that's how it
goes well you're right but you're right
you have to suffer the pain to enjoy the
joy um john let me talk to you first of
all about this issue over the uh this
series is coming out on disney plus
about the sex pistols you know when you
all watch that clip you you guys really
were one of the all-time great bads not
for very long
the longevity of the band but you were
magnificent
and it seems entirely right and proper
that there should be this series but
you've fallen out with the band members
over it why
uh because they put it together behind
my back without mentioning it to me at
all until january the fourth last year
then we got an email from danny boyle on
the 8th saying that he would like to
discuss it with us and on the 9th the
we're over the weekend the press were
banging on my door
and on the the following monday
uh it was released all over the internet
as a done and dusted deal actors were
appointed scripts were written plots
were
fully fully covered but without me so
this tv series they could call it a
documentary i'd prefer mockumentary
uh it's completely without me
contributing in any way shape or form
and i don't think to be absolutely
honest anyone could ever consider the
sex pistols without the man what wrote
the song right
well i completely agree i mean
it's a great shame because danny boyle's
doing it he's a top director you know i
don't know have you seen any of the of
the series
no i haven't been allowed to see
anything at all
no scripts nothing
do you know any single part of i played
in it nothing and do you have any idea
that bizarre
i agree with your peers it would have
been a fantastic opportunity to really
grasp and and
enjoy the truth of that situation but i
think they've gone for this uh watered
down kind of cop-out that isn't going to
do anybody any good
actually what they're doing is
destroying the sex pistols which is a
great great shame and you know i was
reminded of the sex because when you
when you see that magnificent anthem
which got everyone going and got banned
and the rest of it god saved the queen
at the time you know it was back at the
silver jubilee 1977. and at the time it
was a kind of rant against the monarchy
you were young and knarking punks as
you've got older uh john have you
softened your view of the monarchy
i didn't i did
pierce
let someone talk i didn't write it
specifically for the jubilee that was my
train of thought and it was some several
several months before we did that boat
party
um
it's it's very anti-royalist but it's
not anti-human
right i've got to tell the world this
you mustn't presume that i'm completely
dead against the royal family as human
beings i'm not i'm actually really
really proud of the queen for surviving
and doing so well
i i applaud her for that that's a
fantastic achievement i'm not a
curmudgeon about that
i just think that if i'm paying my tax
money to support this system i should
have a say so on how it's spent and do
you think john
do you think possibly the end of the
monarchy because prince charles is not
going to be able to handle it this is
the man that plays pink floyd to his
cabbages
remember that
so you think we might be seeing the the
beginning of the end of the monarchy as
the queen enters the sort of twilight of
her life possibly possibly possibly and
that's a shame in itself too because uh
i do love pageantry you know i mean i'm
a football fan how could i not you know
i like uh i like watching royal weddings
because i really did enjoy watching
spitfires and b-52s and the likes flying
over the palace i get i get quite
emotional with all that yeah i love my
country i love me people and everything
about it but if there's problems within
it i think i have the right to say so
and when i wrote god save the queen and
believe me i wrote it not not the others
right
this is me expressing my fully competent
point of view what do you make john what
do you mean you're more than welcome to
disagree no no no at all your title your
opinions this show is called piers
morgan uncensored i i absolutely want an
uncensored john lydon what do you think
talking of being uncensored about megan
and harry and their contribution to the
royal debate at the moment
i
i i'm sorry but i think that they've uh
showed themselves to be a parasites if
you want to opt out of that family
situation then please by all means do
and go and work for mcdonald's but don't
expect me to be still forking money out
to support your nonsense
uh they seem to be amazingly ungrateful
or at least he is
yeah and as for the sex scandals
involving the other son
well you know les said best said until
that turns up in court
uh i think uh as as public figures if
you don't want to be a public figure
then shut your mouth
[Laughter]
what do you make john of the it was a
survey came out today about
woke and wokeness 36 of the public
apparently in the uk think the woke is
an insult but 26 percent think it's a
compliment do you identify as woke
it well certainly not my advice to the
woke is to please wake up
it's uh it's a lot of uh
typewriter warriors on the internet
isn't it doing this stuff and creating
idolized fantasies for themselves in in
the privacy of their own bedrooms that
their mum and dads are paying for and
unfortunately uh left-leaning
politicians have grabbed on to that and
seen that as their new potential
uh voter base
and that's where it's going wrong
because once politicians uh declare
themselves as woke well we're all doomed
the reason i love you
i think it's a current i think it's a
current fashionable trend that will end
very very sadly for them because it
really is all about being selfish yeah
and ultimately if the ambition is that
we're all woke then you've achieved
nothing
yeah i agree i mean the thing i love
about you john and i'd say this was
great sincerity whenever i've
interviewed you you are literally
uncensored and uncensorable no one has
ever told you what you can and can't say
and you wouldn't listen to them if they
did but so many people now including
many people in the music industry are
terrified of saying the right thing in
the wrong thing worried about being
cancelled by this canceled culture what
do you make of the fear that everyone's
now living in
well i i think that that shows you that
a lot of people don't actually know how
to think
see i i don't just jump to conclusions i
spend most of my life studying and
observing my fellow human beings so i
tend to know what i'm saying
it's not just sloganeering for me or
trying to jump onto a bandwagon
and uh that's how it should be for all
of us uh
let all those that follow the nonsense
sync with that ship
now john i wanted to just end by
mentioning that madonna another sort of
bad
bad rebel of of music if you like
has released some nfts these
non-fundable whatever they are tokens uh
of apparently of scans of her genitals
uh and what i wonder was whether you
might be bidding for them
[Laughter]
i i think if my memory serves me well
i've seen the real thing and i never
ever want to be reminded
online as always nft
yeah nft's interesting to me because i'm
get i'm getting involved in it myself
because i'm a bit of a painter on the
side and i'm raising money for uh
alzheimer's victims for an organization
called spitz out of islington you know
the area i was brought up in um and
we'll be sending musicians to the local
care centers brilliant and uh and
because music as i well know my wife
with alzheimer's now music helps her
brain open up and get to thinking don't
let people with alzheimer's sit and
vegetate involve them in things yeah and
so yeah i found a way to do that not
only for me and wife but with other
people and also i'll be planting trees
all over ireland because there's too
many golf courses
and that's an organization yeah it's an
organization called paramilitary
john unfortunately we are running
outside but finally i wanted to ask you
one question if you could relive one
moment from your time with the sex
pistols right now which moment would you
choose
uh
i suppose uh the first day's rehearsal
all right when i i
became alarmingly aware that these lads
really hadn't much going for them and i
had a golden opportunity to use all the
writings and thoughts i had in my head
and put it to music
and that was
just a most fantastic rewarding feeling
now anybody looking back at the pistols
please remember with fondness just how
vital and important we were not this new
nonsense
john you were vital you were important i
think you still are vital and important
you're a fantastic guest on any show
like this always it's great to talk to
you and all the very best to you and to
your wife
may the road rise with you and your
enemies always be behind you made a
scatter flatter battle chatter
[Laughter]
john lyden thank you great to talk to
you
what a character
you